i have already put down the deposit do
you understand how a deposit works mike
i am not having fire eaters in a paper
warehouse it's casino night like las
vegas or fire eaters all over the place
except my warehouse well actually it's
my warehouse actually it's owned by
beekman properties and dunder mifflin is
four years into a seven year lease
why are you here
when daryl was coming you said you
wanted me here for protection
that
i said not that
we just have a lot of stuff down there
that could be stolen
that's ironic what
that you are afraid
why because i'm from the hood
dink and flicker
thinking flicker
i told mike some uh some phrases
to help with his interracial
conversations
you know stuff like fleece it out
going mach 5 dinkin flicker
you know things as negroes say
give me something
oh yeah uh um i thought of a handshake
too you gave him full immunity are you
insane you told me to cut a deal i
thought you'd maybe drop charges on one
or two felonies but do you know how many
crimes we're forgiving six that's not so
bad hundred oh that's way more grand
theft auto grand theft auto grand theft
auto dog fraud i saw the guy fake
peeking knees
towards the cat you will not win me over
with your use of twas i wasn't trying to
ladies and gentlemen
widows and widowers welcome to the all
ages piano lounge adults only show
i'm horatio velveteen dope name this
little song i wrote myself
call it rosa rosarosa
goes like this
rosa
rosa
[Music]
and the lighting is way too sexy to see
anything
right there on the floor
is the man you're looking for
he's right in front of you
a little bit to the left
my left my left my left my left
come on this way
he's in a red church
no not the asian dude
i'm talking about a bright red shirt
that's the man you're looking for
that's the man you've been looking for i
got a this is still a love song people
come on
this is still a love song
where'd he go well that ends my show all
of a sudden you've been a great crowd
thank you very much think of me when you
smush you know this has been very
informative and all that but you think
we
hey hey it's the line you didn't
[Applause]
that doesn't help us our neck
[Music]
damn it feels good to be on the same
team for once coppin criminal working
together
we need a theme song
the pontiac bandit and jager cops oh
taking down crooks in the streets where
they live flirting with girls who are
hopping a bath there's a talking police
dog that helps them solve crime
[Music]
oh it's hard mike
breakups hurt
we didn't break it up
sometimes when i'm down like this
it helps to sing the blues
okay
no
[Music]
you hear me what's getting you down
no wait
and jake rolling down the street pb and
jay a tasty little tree two cool dudes
making saddles for your feet what i was
going for the rhyme but now i kind of
feel like it's a good idea love it
making sandals that last is our ideology
made real by our patented strapless
technology it's magnets oh okay yo you
can wear them on the beach wear them on
a hike wear them on a peloton exercise
bike doug and jake
two best friends with the premium
orbital shoes for men
that was crazy you never even rehearsed
it just did it perfectly it was like
jackson made an alley i called ali ah i
wanted ali
comfortable mike
yeah
about you man come on
no
don't ever touch a black man radio
or stalker
i won't touch yours by the way
thank you
i've been in new york in a long time
maybe i'll stay overnight
we got a cousin live down here
how do we get home
oh you could stay too yeah he's got a
big place
it's not that big
buses though get you home quick
hey guys
janna's ready for you
okay
bring it home now and don't forget the
new black man phrase i taught you
bippity poppy give me the zombie yes sir
remember that
i'll be right outside if you need me all
right
yeah
tell mike some new phrases
i want him to get the raise
just can't help myself
before you meet her i do have to come
clean
you were right i'm not really friends
with tasha she wrote in my uber and i
thought he really hit it off but she
never responded to any of the follow-up
texts i ever sent her i don't care if
she's your friend jillian g i can't if
she works next to a wetsuit okay wow
that is crazy it really is do you know
what else is crazy the fact that you and
i never hung out after we totally hit it
off i mean i idled at your destination
for like six minutes so we could finish
our conversation remember i think i was
drunk
right that makes sense that's so tasha
can we hurry up and get this thing off
me please yeah let me just fire up the
cool sculpting machine
cool sculpting machine yeah well it's
made for fat freezing but i think i can
probably get the snake real cold and
then just crack it off but no no you got
to give me anesthesia and then sew me
back up yeah this is a med spa i was
really only trained for the
coolsculpting it was like a two-day
seminar in boca that's why i get to wear
this cool coat [ __ ] this i'm out take me
to a real doctor you still want to
pretend you had nothing to do with this
i didn't and she didn't either judy
judy's not a car thief trudy judy's an
angel she's putting herself through
nursing school and nurses are the best
of our society name one bad nurse nurse
ratchet kathy bates in misery nurse
jackie had a pill problem okay damn you
got a lot of real good examples off the
top of your head you believe me right
jake i mean the fact pattern's not great
but trudy did seem very nice when i met
her are you trying to get your freak on
with my sister what no i see you looking
at tritty judy's booty i am not looking
at trudy judy's booty oh you don't think
she's a cutie don't be snooty she's a
beauty but i'm on duty and you're
married oh yeah but that doesn't rise
you